mais d'abord je voudrais commencer par
le single qui s'appelle justement de
tant de belles choses comme l'album
alors c'est l'histoire d'une personne
qui doit partir qui s'adresse à un
enfant un ami un amant ce n'est pas
vraiment un et qui tente de le consoler
avec des idées positives voilà j'ai
toujours été intéressé par par la
spiritualité si on perd le sens de la
vie qu'est ce qu'on fait là pour qu'on
est là et serra et j'ai toujours eu
l'impression bon c'est peut-être très
banal ce que je vais dire mais que que
la mort c'est qui est certainement un
moment très pénible pour tout le monde
sauf pour les gens qui meurent en
dormant peut-être c'était la libération
de l'esprit qui est libéré subitement dû
subitement parfois très lentement du
matériel du physique et qui va dans un
autre espace temps et je pense que à
partir du moment où il ya des liens très
forts entre les êtres
le fait que l'un des deux quelqu'un
meure avant avant les êtres qu'il aime
ne détruit pas le lien simplement le
corps n'est plus là mais l'esprit est là
ailleurs je croise vous croyez aux
forces de l'esprit
je crois à l'existence de l'esprit